-Our first guest tonight
is a United States Senator
from Vermont and a former
presidential candidate.
Please welcome back to the sho
our friend
Senator Bernie Sanders.
How are you, Senator?
-I'm waving with my left hand.
How's that?
-[ Laughs ] Good, see?
We've got a good Zoom
connection with you.
That's a great sign.
And may I just say,
we've commented on it
on our show before,
I'm a big fan of your backdrops.
They're always very nature
themed, they're very pleasant.
And in these trying times,
I feel like they bring a littl
calm to the proceedings.
-And also we're trying to ge
people to come visit us
here in the state of Vermont
That's how beautiful it is
-[ Laughs ]
Very nicely done.
You are no stranger to
the importance of voter turnout.
One of your first election
as the mayor of Burlington
Vermont -- true story --
you only won by 10 votes.
Is that correct?
-After a recount, that's right
-So I think that, you know
one of the reasons that many
are optimistic about forme
Vice President Biden's chances
is that young voters,
a lot of the voters
that powered your campaign
are going to vote for Joe Biden.
What would you say to anybod
today who is still on the fence?
-Well, Seth,
let me just say this,
that the younger generatio
in America today,
and we should all be proud
of that as parents, is probabl
the most progressive generatio
in the history of this country
It's the generation
that's anti-racist, anti-sexist,
anti-homophobia,
anti-religious/bigotry.
And it appears that they are
finally,
finally beginning to vote
in large numbers.
In Texas and in Georgia,
young people are coming ou
in droves,
which could have
a significant impact
on traditional
Republican states.
And that's true
all over this country.
So that, I think,
is a great thing.
And, by the way,
it will go beyond this election.
I think it's transformativ
for American society
if young people
get deeply involved
in the political process,
and we are seeing that.
In terms of what I would say t
people who are still undecided
look, the election essentially
is about two things.
If you feel comfortable
about having
and continue to have a president
who is a pathological liar
a president who does not believe
in the Constitution
or the rule of law,
and a president
who does not believe in science,
and when you don't believe
in science,
you cannot address the pandemi
that we're seeing today,
where the United States no
has the highest per capita
death rate
for COVID-19 of
any major country on Earth
You cannot address
the existential threat
of climate change
unless you believe in science.
Trump does not. Biden does
And the other point that I would
make that goes
beyond Donald Trump,
and that is we need a government
that begins to pay attention
to a working class
in America today
that is in very,
very serious trouble.
Unemployment, very high.
Wages, very low.
90 million people uninsure
or underinsured.
People cannot afford their
prescription drugs they need
Kids cannot afford
to go to college
or are leaving school
deeply in debt.
18 million families spending
half of their limited
income on housing.
So we have got to begin
addressing the major crise
facing working families
in this country.
Trump
certainly has not done that.
Biden will begin to do that,
and that's terribly important.
So I think those are
the basic reasons
why people have got to get out
and vote and vote for Biden.
-I think you would probabl
admit that the Democratic Part
got away from the
working class a little bit
This was a far more reliable
bloc for the Democratic Part
maybe in the '50s
and the '60s than it is today.
Say that in a Biden presidency
should it come to pass,
what would you encourage him
to do to
bring the Democratic Party bac
to serving the working peopl
in this country?
-Well, Seth, you're making
a very important point
that is not made often enough,
to be honest with you.
And that is I think it is fair
to say
that in many ways
the Democratic Party
has become a party
of the coastal elites,
folks who have a lot of money,
upper-middle-class people,
who are good people
who believe in social justic
in many respects.
But I think for many,
many years,
the Democratic Party has not
paid the kind of attention
to working-class needs
that they should have.
And that has a lot to do wit
who funds campaigns, et cetera
So I think what we have
got to do --
and let me just tell you,
we are working right now,
as the United States Senator
from Vermont,
I am working on
a 100-day program
to get the Democratic Party,
if we gain control
over the Senate,
to start bursting out
of the blocs
in an effort
to protect working people.
So what do we have to do?
First of all, immediately,
we have to do what
Mitch McConnell has not done
and that is pass
a very substantive
COVID-19 emergency relief bill
to help the millions of people
who are unemployed,
who have lost their income
and lost their healthcare.
And that means
an extension of that $600
supplement to unemployment
It means a $1,200 check
for working families,
working individuals
all over this country.
It means providing healthcare to
those people who have lost it,
aid to cities and towns so the
don't have to lay off workers.
Second of all, we need to rais
the minimum wage
to a living wage,
at least 15 bucks an hour,
make it easier for workers
to join unions.
Equal pay for equal work
for women.
We have got to expand healthcare
to all people.
We are the only major countr
on Earth
that does not guarantee
healthcare to all people,
and that's what
we have got to do.
We have got to deal
with criminal justice.
We have to deal
with immigration,
so there is a ton of stuff
that has to be done,
but in the process, we've go
to raise wages.
We've got to create
millions of good-paying jobs
by rebuilding our infrastructure
and transforming our energ
system away from fossil fuel
to energy efficiency
and sustainable energy.
But apropos of what you said
if the Democratic Party
does not stand firmly
for working families
and have the courage to take o
the drug companies
and the insurance companie
and the big-money interests,
shame on them.
-A very surreal thing
has happened in the time
since you --
I should say since Joe Biden
has become the nominee,
which is Donald Trump,
in ways, still seems
to be running against you.
He brings you up both
as an example
of what the party will be
under a Joe Biden presidency
how far left it will be,
and other times he seems
to be courting
Bernie Sanders supporters
as the perfect
Donald Trump voters.
How has it been for you
to watch him sort of --
this weird sort of triangulation
of what it means
to be a Bernie voter in so far
as how it relates to him?
-Well, first thought,
we understand
that Trump lies all of the time.
And he's saying,
"Oh, we're going to get
all kinds of Bernie supporters."
He's not.
The overwhelming majority
of our supporters
are going to be voting for Biden
because they understand
that we cannot have four
more years of Donald Trump
That's clear.
But I think what he also
understands --
you know, when he goes to thes
rallies is that,
our campaign,
when I was running,
had the largest rallies,
I believe.
We had 25,000, 30,000 people
coming out,
and we have
really strong support.
People feel deeply
about the issues
that I and other progressive
have raised.
And Trump is conscious of that
He understands that we hav
supporters who desperately
desperately are demanding
that we pass a Medicare-for-al
single-payer program,
that we deal
with climate change,
with the systemic racism
and a terrible
immigration system,
that our people feel
passionately about the nee
to transform America and creat
a government that works for all.
He understands that.
-Last thing I want to ask you,
you know, in the years
since you've become sort of more
of a national figure
with your presidential
campaigns,
I think one of the things
that people
maybe would have expected leas
is how you have
become close with,
friends with Dua Lipa,
Halsey, Cardi B., Killer Mike.
-[ Laughs ]
-We obviously have talked
about your young support.
Were you familiar with
these artists five years ago
-You're not going to tell
anybody, right,
if I give you the answer here?
-I promise. This is all off air.
-Just between you and me, right?
-[ Laughs ]
-No, I was not,
but I will tell you this.
You know, just talking to Du
and to other
of these young singers,
I find them to
be extremely bright
and extremely engaged,
and they understand.
In terms of Dua, I was looking
you know, at Instagram.
Her songs have like
500 million views.
Can you believe that?
500 -- you know,
we got very excited
if we got 2 million views.
-[ Laughs ] Right.
-500 million views
all over the world.
And what she and the others,
Halsey and others,
understand that
it's important to use their fame
and the kind of support
they have
to bring young people
into the political process
And I think that
that's a beautiful thing.
-Well, it is --
they're some of my favorit
conversations to watch
and it's also wonderful to b
on the other side of
a conversation with you as well.
Thank you so much
for being here, Senator.
-My pleasure.